now here's thing you're on stage in the
West End and obviously people come to
see you and you get confident yet
nervous but do you think notice when
your family come because they they don't
sugarcoat what they think do they know
they they my family they they're very
supportive but they don't feel the need
to you know if they don't like something
or they weren't that impressed or they
were a bit bored they'll say for example
the native made in Dagenham it was a
huge deal for me cuz I'm not really a
singer and I've been practicing and my
mum came and she went hmm
voice has gotten better but you know in
a way is she's ready because Miriam
without you didn't I guess in you don't
sugarcoat things you get stars talking
to me Michael I do sometimes I do
sometimes I remember when I was young I
and I met Laurence Olivier well that was
I used to collect autographs at the
stage door no and he came out and I
remember so distinctly that I started to
cream in my knickers I could
wherever we thought that story was going
I honestly don't think I've ever been
more uncomfortable
I think that's the worst moment of my
life
well that's a lovely story mirror thank
you for sharing I think that's in the
compilation that's that's great tribute
no greater compliment Miriam yes I think
we should all get fans out
that's not true because you'll be here
well you I'm gonna be here yes that that
it's not the French reunion that
everybody's hoping for what is the name
of Chandler's father's all-male
burlesque
I actually know that - that's Viva Las
Vegas